哈喽大家好,我是熊高
欢迎来到这个有钱一起赚的投资理财频道
这集要和大家分享
如何用1.5万美元
做到1.5亿美元的投资策略
而这策略竟然是有一名
没有任何金融背景
且在平凡不过的年轻人
却在一场乌龙事件里
发现市场上
竟然隐藏这么一名投资高手
他以均线乖离率策略
和动能讯号的交易方式
并透过他独有的交易风格
让他在短短几年的时间
就翻了数万倍的投资收益
他就是有着日本民间股神之称的
小手川龙
因此我不仅要让你学习
他实际使用的交易策略
还要告诉你
这位日本股神的过往经历
是如何影响熊狗战日后交易
能顺利的投资赚钱
并在影片后面
也会和大家分享他的成功秘诀
并不是什么难以做到的方式
而是很多人都误解了
交易赚钱的真正逻辑
因此只要纠正其中的观念
你也能学习到其中的精髓所在
因此如果你想少走冤枉路
并且尽早在投资市场取得成功
那这集影片一定能帮助到你
而为什么会说小手川龙
是个在平凡不过的平凡人
因为他不善于社交的个性
所以总喜欢待在家里
也就是个名副其实的宅男
而他刚开始会接触股票
我想和很多人一样
都是在书籍或网路上
看到有人因投资而从谷底翻身
甚至是成功的精彩故事
期望借此改变自己的人生
而小手穿聋
也是在偶然的情况下
结束了股票入门的书籍
从此热衷于投资市场
让喜欢宅在家里的他
总是长时间宅在家里钻研
直到一起乌龙事件
让他受到全日本人民的关注
也就是在2005年12月
当天日本瑞税证券公司
有个新股准备上市
也就是人才服务公司JayKong
当时将近开盘时
有很多人早已蓄势待发
准备买入股票
而证券商里有名员工
当时收到投资人的指令
把原先该以61万日元的价格
卖出一股J看的股票
但他却首误输入成以每股一日元的价格卖出61万股的股票而他马上发现了这严重的错误这时瑞穗证券多次发出测诞的指令
但是却都失败了
导致他们在一天之内
亏损了将近400亿日元
然而有人亏损
那就有人获利
而这起事件最大的获利者
正是小手穿聋
因当时在发生这件乌龙时
短短10分钟之内
他大量挂单
抢购了7000多股的股票
因此在短短的时间
为他包赚了大约20亿日元
成为这一抗事件中
取得最高获利的交易者
尽管当时有人认为他只是侥幸
但要在短时间如此果决
买入如此庞大的股票
绝对不是偶然
因此他在2005年
这无荣事件受到关注后
在2007年的8月
日本股市发生股灾
投资市场一片惨淡时
小手穿荣也完全不畏惧
依然能让他在市场上
海捞了6.21日元
累积资产也超过200亿日元
那他到底是怎么做到的
我们就来一一拆解
他的策略方式
以下是他的核心交易策略
首先他从来不看公司的财务状况和基本面
只着重于技术线图分析
而他选股的策略
主要选择高波动性与高成交量的股票
比如观察每天涨跌幅前10名的个股
而这样高成交量的股票
通常意味着市场情绪强烈
因此适合短线交易
而因为他是个点钱的短线交易者
持有一档股票的时间
从当天结单
到最多不超过一周的时间
因为它领悟到市场
往往涨跌容易过度反应
导致价格偏离平均成本
因此小手穿荣进场的策略
主要是透过平均线的乖离率
以偏离较大的股票进行购买
而移动平均线的乖离率
可以告诉我们
价格与移动平均线之间的差距
从而帮助我们判断市场
当前趋势和价格
是否偏离正常水平
自然偏离程度越大
股票回升的可能性就越高
這時在觀察MACD的動能指標
看到指標透露出上漲的動能
這時就能進行開倉進場
而在具體了解整個判斷的流程之前
我想要告訴那些
還在摸索適合自己策略的人這時因為還沒有實際在市場上賺到錢所以容易會對自己的判斷沒信心而這時我們可以利用能連結TradeView並且免費使用
裡面付費功能的交易平台
也就是Mightrade
因為在它交易的介面中
有一個很好用的輔助工具
也就是在左邊選項的資訊裡
有對於分析師
提供了各項交易的看法
裡面具體說明了策略方式
甚至注意事項都有特別提醒
但市場變換莫測
我们不能依赖别人的看法
而盲目的进行操作
但我们可以藉由
参考它里面判断走势的观点
然后再经过自身策略进行确认
如果看法一致
不仅能提高成功率
并且能确实掌握交易的根据
而这平台使用的界面不只直观好懂
且还有很多有助于交易的功能
因此如果你也在寻找一个
有利于你交易的交易平台
那MyTrade 绝对是个不错的选择
最重要的是
MyTrade为所有用户
提供资金保护的政策
保单金额高达100万美元
让用户可以放心的
用它来交易全球的各大资产
而我也提供相关资讯
在下方资讯栏
提供给大家做注册
那接下来我们就
直接在michet的界面上
来具体展示小手穿笼
整个判断的流程
首先我们先把指标
新增到图表中
前面有说到
我们会利用
移动平均线的乖离率
了解它是否偏离平均成本
因此我们可以搜寻均线的缩写MA
然后点选第一个
添加到图表中
只要小手穿戎
冠要的参数值为
25日均线
因此我们就点选设置
把长度更改为25
再来要再添加的指标是MACD
同样选择第一个选项
而我们会进行修改
因此在MACD上点选设置
然后点选样式后
将指标上的快慢线移除掉
也就会将MACD
以及信用线勾选取消掉
那指标都设置好之后
就来了解这策略具体的判断流程
那我们就拿回答来做案例分析
首先会先观察
日线图上的趋势是否为下跌趋势
然后再看当时均线的乖离率的标准
至少要为-10%以上
才能作为主要关注的股票
因此也就要来了解
乖离率的计算方式也就会以当前股票平均线的价格与现价价格相减后再除上平均线的价格就难得出因此我们可以看到在日线图上的均线处于向下跌并且看到均线以及价格之间有段距离
然后对照章指价格为94
均线为120
两者相减后为-26
然后在除上120
也就是大约为-0.21
百分比也就是-21%
因此符合-10%以上的标准
则既然小手穿荣是为短线交易者
也就会以较小的时间周期
作为主要的进场根据
而他最喜欢使用的周期
是15分图
因此我们切换后
就能使用MACD动能指标
来确认当时股票的多空动能
也就是当MACD柱体
往后从零轴下
要转回零轴上
表示多方动能增加
就能作为价格
产生回升平均线的讯号
这时也就是
进场做多的时机
而当柱体由大转小
表示动能减弱
也就能立即获利出场
而我们可以在图表中
看到MACD圈起来的地方
也就是柱体在灵轴上方的范围
对照上方图表买卖的位置
在短线交易里
都能够获得利润
而要符合-10%以上的乖利率
在市场中相对有限
因此这策略
只是小手穿荣其中一种策略方式
而往后也会分享更多
已经在市场上验证
成功的交易策略
而当我研究了市场上的成功人士
发现他们都有个共同点
就是当面临较大的行情走势
一般人都会因为
生怕错过了大好的赚钱机会
因此急于进行操作
但这些成功投资人
他们对于不符合自己策略的市场讯号
就算市场有多大的行情
也丝毫不会被动摇
因为他们清楚
投资的利润
是透过策略在适合的位置进行操作
才能掌握实际能赚钱的获利空间
因此让我意识到
如果只是盲目的追求每一波的行情走势
只是毫无根据
那就跟赌博没两样
自然没办法投资赚钱的
因此如果你也有这样不良的行为
那请你立刻停止
懂得遵循策略能掌握的利润
才真正能在市场上赚了长久
而对于这期影片
交易策略的使用
有什么想和熊导讨论的地方
也欢迎在下方留言
最后也不忘送上
很重要的一句话
那就是别忘了
按赞订阅
开启小铃铛
我们下期不见不散
拜拜咯